it is Friday which means it's time to
get you all caught up on everything that
matters in gaming this week you guys
seem to love getting stuff for free so
here's how you can weasel your way into
the division beta on ps4 without passing
with any of your dollars unfortunately
we recently discovered that this sneaky
method of beta access no longer works
but earlier this week you could search
to the game on the playstation store
click pre-order and then select
pre-order and pay then you search for
and download the division's beta client
after which you could locate your
pre-order transaction through the
settings menu and cancel it
congratulations to those of you who paid
attention earlier on this week and
managed to grab it those of you with a
taste for brutal games will be happy to
hear we can learn more info about Dark
Souls 3 this week bandai namco released
a series of screenshots that show up a
whole bunch of new and terrifying craft
that includes a new box named EDX gun
deer who wields a massive spear and will
be encountered by players and a location
called the untended graves the images
also showcased the filing shrine which
serves as a starting area for new
players are sol 3 is due out on april 12
in the west
poor Peter Molyneux was the victim of a
Twitter hack this week which led his
followers to believe he was taken go to
Stanton spin and with tiring the string
of fake tweet was a bit too real reading
this is also the time I would like to
announce my retirement from the games
industry it has been a long journey for
me thank you overall my time in the
industry has been bittersweet however my
biggest mistake was fable 3 it pushed me
and my team to the limits fortunately
the confusion was over quickly when the
real Peter Molyneux stood up and tweeted
on my account has been hacked you can
tell because they know how to spell I am
NOT retiring not closing goddess Sony
and Microsoft have announced the free
games you can pick up next month with
their respective online subscriptions on
ps4 you can grab yourself nom nom galaxy
while ps3 users can pick up grid
Autosport and persona 4 arena ultimate n
PS Vita players will be able to get Nova
111 and the lemmings touch on top of
that the exceptionally fun Helldivers is
available across all three platforms for
free with your subscription if you have
an xbox live gold subscription you can
grab hand of fate throughout next month
and sticks master of shadow between
februari 16 and month 15 on xbox one on
xbox 360 you can pick up sacred Citadel
in the first half of the month and gears
of war two in the second
finally he revealed a bunch of
interesting stats in their latest
earnings call on thursday the publisher
revealed that star wars battlefront has
shipped more than 13 million copies
which is coincidentally the number that
EA announced they'd expected the game
which [ __ ] it's worth noting that this
figure represents the number of copies
that have been shipped to retailers and
not those sold through to consumers
overall the company posted almost 600
million bucks in profit for the last
quarter and revealed that star wars the
old republic has reached its highest
subscriber level in three years let me
know down at you make comment section
what you cared about this week and if
you're getting stuck into the division
beta this week I talk to you about some
super sad games ambitious we take a look
at games that have gone missing this
year and things you missed takes a look
at the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
trailer that is everything I wanted to
tell you about this week as always be
sure to have yourself a lovely weekend
and I will catch you again on Monday